dos autos se dirigen a una intersección
desde direcciones perpendiculares la
velocidad del primer auto es de 50
kilómetros por hora y la velocidad del
segundo auto es de 90 kilómetros por
hora en el momento t sub zero el primer
auto se encuentra a una distancia x dt
sub 0 de 5 kilómetros de la intersección
y el segundo auto está a una distancia
de 7 sub zero de 1.2 kilómetros de la
intersección cuál es la tasa de cambio
de la distancia de dt entre los autos en
ese instante que ecuación debe usarse
para resolver el problema aquí vemos que
tenemos cuatro opciones como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de encontrar la respuesta correcta antes
de que la resolvamos juntos aquí algo
que nos ayuda a comprender lo que está
pasando es dibujar lo que nos dicen en
el enunciado vamos a hacerlo nos dicen
que dos autos se dirigen a una
intersección desde direcciones
perpendiculares dibujamos un auto que se
mueve en la dirección x hacia la
intersección que está por acá y ahora
dibujamos el otro auto que se mueve en
la dirección y hacia la misma
intersección luego nos dicen que en el
momento
t sub zero que es el instante que vamos
a representar en este dibujo el primer
auto está a una distancia x de sub 0 de
5 kilómetros aquí en el dibujo marcamos
esta distancia como x dt y esta otra
distancia es de 7 ahora cómo se
relaciona la distancia de los autos con
x de 7 pues podemos usar la fórmula de
la distancia que es en esencia el
teorema de pitágoras y aquí tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo así que la
distancia entre los autos es la
hipotenusa que es la raíz cuadrada de x
dt al cuadrado más llueve t al cuadrado
todo esto es igual a de t podemos decir
que de dt al cuadrado es igual a x dt al
cuadrado más gente al cuadrado esta es
la relación entre debe txd7 esto es útil
para resolver el problema porque ahora
podemos calcular la derivada de ambos
lados de la ecuación con respecto a t y
usaremos varias herramientas para hacer
esto incluyendo la regla de la cadena lo
que al final no será la tasa de cambio
de la distancia de dt
77 si vemos las opciones nos damos
cuenta de que la opción de muestra la
relación que acabamos de analizar el
cuadrado de la distancia entre los autos
es igual al cuadrado de la distancia x a
la intersección más el cuadrado de la
distancia a la intersección luego
podemos calcular la derivada de ambos
lados de esta igualdad para encontrar la
relación de la tasa de cambio que nos
preguntan con eso terminamos y nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo